So now you know,
where fragments are used
and where we're going
to use them in our app.
You're probably starting to ask,
why use fragments at all?
If we want to group UI components,
couldn't we just create
a View Group,
or maybe a re-usable
XML layout definition?
Yes, but the real power in fragments
goes beyond grouping UI elements.
They allow us to fully modularize
our activities,
including the life cycle
events they receive
in the app state that they maintain.
Fragments were first introduced
in Honeycomb
to solve a particular problem.
Honeycomb was the first Android release
to support tablet's
and it turned out,
the best way for most apps
to create a great tablet UI
was to put two or more
of their phone activities
alongside each other.
For example, if you had a phone app
that started with a list activity
like this,
which you then clicked an item,
would open a detailed activity
like this one.
What we call a Master Detail Flow.
A good tablet UI would put them
side by side like this.
Functionally, clicking an item
on this list,
now replaces this activity on the right,
rather than starting a new one,
as it would have done
here on the phone.
Now, unfortunately,
Android didn't always support
embedding activities
within other activities.
At least, it didn't,
until we introduced fragments.
Now, if you just look
at the UI elements,
you could be excused for thinking
that you could achieve
much the same thing
using an activity
that was built using
U Groups and layouts,
without bothering with fragments,
which is true,
up to a point.
But then you'd have to pass through
all of the activity life cycle events,
manage the state
of each piece of the UI,
keep track of the state of each
of the portions as they changed,
and remember
which screen elements
were on screen
at any given time,
in order to maintain app state.
All of which, is exactly
what the Fragment Manager
does for you,
when you use Fragments.
And that let's you
take a step back
and treat each fragment
as though it were a mini activity.
For example, in the world of activities,
you start one activity from the other,
and that transaction
is recorded on the back stack.
So, hitting the Back button,
will undo that transaction
and bring the first activity
to the front.
Now, the same thing can happen
with fragment transactions.
In this case, rather than starting
a new activity,
we simply replace the list fragment
with the detail fragment.
And then, the Back button
will undo that transaction
and reverse it.
So in theory, you can really take
any app with multiple activities
and replace it with a single activity
that's host to multiple fragments.